around Facebook's IPO there was just
there was so much hype
regular retail investors Keeble with
retirement funds teenagers who use that
everyone wanted to invest right after it
went public it's hate Facebook stocks
slipped on concerns that they weren't
going to be able to figure out this
growing shift of their users to mobile
phones but eventually they did put these
promoted posts at work so well on
desktop computers into their mobile app
this was driven by Sheryl Sandberg who
was really trying to encourage marketers
to spend on mobile Zuckerberg himself
told engineers to build mobile first in
fact if they didn't present the mobile
side of their apps first at meetings he
would start a brand Facebook has 1.65
billion users in order to continue to
grow they need to have other properties
they acquired Instagram for 700 million
around the time of their IPO a couple
years later they acquired whatsapp for
22 billion they also spun off messenger
the facebook chat service into its own
app this multi app strategy is helping
Facebook think of other ways to generate
revenue beyond the main app now Facebook
makes more than 80 percent of its
revenue from mobile up from zero at the
time of its IPO prospectus so that's a
really driven this growth in Facebook
stock and it's now more than triple its
IPO value when companies are growing as
fast as Facebook is it's very easy to
forgive their mistakes they've had some
apps that never got off the ground some
acquisitions that never got done but as
long as the revenue keeps growing to
record highs Wall Street's gonna turn a
blind eye and say Zuckerberg do whatever
you want